[موسيقى]
لا يستطيع هذا الصحفي الروسي تسجيل مثل
هذا البرنامج في بلده
الانظمه الديكتاتوريه مثل النظام في روسيا
لا تعرف كيف تحارب لان احدا لا يستطيع ان
يعارض او ينتقد ما يقوله رئيس الدوله
بعد وقت قصير من غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا
اصدرت موسكو احكاما بالسجن بحق صحفيين
معارضين متهمه اياهم بنشر معلومات مضلله
كيريل مارلينوف فر الى
هربا من الرقابه
كان قرارا لابد من اتخاذه فقد فهمنا
مباشره في تلك اللحظه اننا سنواجه المشاكل
بعملنا تحت ظل اداره الرئيس
بوتينوف رئيس تحرير جريده روسيه مستقله
شهيره وقد لحق به حوالي 30 صحفيا روسيا
لتقديم رؤيه جديده مختلفه للعمل الاعلامي
هذا المكان
المحليه استاجرناه واصبح المقر الجديد
لجريدتنا
هدف هيئه التحرير هنا هو تقديم المعلومات
للمجتمع الروسي من الخارج
لا يمكن مقال كهذا في روسيا حاليا لانه لا
يمكن الحديث عن الحرب باعتبارها حربا
وانما عمليه عسكريه خاصه
لدينا باستمرار اشخاص في روسيا يقدمون لنا
المعلومات وطبعا نحن حذرون جدا في التعامل
مع هؤلاء الصحفيين
منذ بدايه الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا منحت
لاتفيا مئات التاشيرات الى الصحافيين
الفاريين من روسيا مئات المثقفين الروس
منفيون هنا ايضا ويعيش الكثير منهم في
منطقه تقع غرباريه من المفارقات الغريبه
ان هذا المنتجع الساحلي كان مخصصا للمدراء
السوفييت ابان حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي وهنا
تعيش الينا لوكيانوفا
اصيبت استاذه القانون الدستوري الروسي
بصدمه بعد غزو بلادها لاوكرانيا
صنعنا اكثر من اربعين الف شمعه
يتم ارسال المواد الغذائيه والدواء
والملابس الى الجنود الاوكرانيين ترسل هذه
الجمعيه الاطنان من الطرود الانسانيه كل
اسبوع كنوع من المساهمه في المعركه
سرق حياتنا ومخططاتنا للمستقبل
بدات الجمعيه بتقديم الدعم الى المقاتلين
والى المدنيين ايضا مباشره بعد الغزو اي
بعد اقل من اسبوع من شنه وقد خصصت وقتها
هذا المستودع للمهمه قلنا في بدايه اننا
لسنا في حاجه الى كل هذا المكان المتسع
ولكن ادركنا بعد مرور السنه اننا نحتاج
الى مكان اكثر اتساعا اعتقد كما يعتقد
جميع المتطوعين هنا ان المعركه ليست معركه
الاوكرانيين فقط
تذكر هذه المعركه بفتره الاحتلال السوفيتي
الذي استمر حتى عام 91 من القرن الماضي
الحكومه بدات مباشره بازاله جميع الرموز
التي يمكن ان تذكر بتلك الفتره المؤلمه
المخصصه للجيش الاحمر في الصيف الماضي
خلف هذه الاسوار كان ينتصب عملاق حجري
ارتفاعه 79 مترا
هذه الاثار ليست تاريخيه وانما ايديولوجيه
غير الهجوم الروسي ضد كير من التصورات
العامه والاوروبيه الغربيه المتعلقه
بالروايات الروسيه التي بنيت حول تاريخ
الاتحاد السوفيتي وايديولوجيته
تمت ازاله مئات المعالم الاثريه التي تذكر
بتلك الحقبه في جميع انحاء البلاد ولم
يتبقى سوى بعض الرموز القليله
هنا مثلا لا يزال رمز المنجل والمطرقه
ظاهرا وستتم ازالته قريبا هذه السياسه لم
يتم تقبلها كما يجب من قبل جزء من المجتمع
من الناطقين بالروسيه هم يشكلون اكثر من
ثلث عدد سكان لاتفيا بقليل لا يزالون
مرتبطين بروسيا يمكن لهذه المعركه ضد
فلاديمير بوتين ان تتيح لهذا البلد ان
يقلب صفحه الحقبه السوفييتيه من تاريخه
بشكل نهائي